welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka baby yolo
in this video we're breaking down
everything you need to know about the
mandalorian
this is gonna get you fully caught up
for season two and obviously there will
be heavy spoilers here
so if you still think you have time to
catch up before it starts next week
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now don't forget to drop a thumbs up
as this is the way we know you enjoyed
the video and make sure you subscribe
as the force will be with you always
with all those crap buttons out the way
thank you for clicking this
now let's get into the recap okay so the
mandalorian is set
five years after the return of the jedi
and we discover that the rebellion have
had a lot of difficulty when it comes to
restabilizing order amongst the galaxy
because of this there's a sort of power
vacuum that exists
and several imperial forces that wish to
step up and seize control once more
you can sort of see the pieces forming
here that would go on to play a big part
in the force awakens and we joined in
joran as he's given a task that ends up
becoming intrinsically linked to his
fate
dynjoran is also known as the
mandalorian and we discovered throughout
the season that he was actually rescued
by the creed when he was a child
and since then has joined their ranks in
his childhood
dyn's family and home were wiped out by
separatist forces
and thus he's grown a dislike for droids
however he still
experienced a lot as part of the
mandalorians
and grew up traveling the galaxy as part
of their forces
this is referred to as being a foundling
and dyn
is completely loyal to the creed
refusing to even remove his helmet
in front of anyone but it smells like
jabba's [ __ ] under there but
on navarro he's given a job by a
high-ranking member of the imperial
forces
who's only ever called the client this
involves travelling to avala 7
and picking up a target which we
discover is baby yoda
on the planet he meets an ugnort named
queel and also another bounty hunter
droid named ig-11
who mando ends up shooting in order to
save baby yoda from being executed
now we learn very little about baby yoda
and truth be told
you should actually be referred to as
the child but hey the name's stuck
and i refuse to take back all those
memes jump to episode 2
and after showers dismantle parts of
mando's ship quill helps the character
to strike up a deal with them
and the entry revolves primarily around
mano getting the egg of a mud horn
so that the jawas can party like it's
four thousand nine hundred and ninety
nine
mando is nearly killed by the mud horn
but baby yoda uses its force powers to
save him
and that's when he becomes attached to
the child curious to learn about its
mystical ways
oh fun theory yeah a jedi mind tricked
him into ruining his life
anyway manor returns to the client with
the child and he's paid in best car
steel which he uses to upgrade his
armor mano has a change of heart though
and decides not to abandon baby odor to
his fate
and thus he returns to the imperial
hideout and rescues the child
busting out some amazing weapons in the
process
however because he went back on the deal
that he had he's now been ostracized by
the bounty hunters guild
and they attempt to go after him mando
is saved by his own clan
and when escaping he comes face to face
with his handler grief karger
who mando ends up shooting in order to
get away kaga survives this
but mando's creed is not so lucky and we
later learn that the majority of them
were hunted and killed because of this
betrayal
but we'll get into that more in just a
bit from here mando and baby yoda travel
to sorghum which is where they meet an
ex-rebel shock trooper
named beep bop boop so sorry cara june
she and mando end up working together in
order to save a group of farmers on the
planet
and it's probably one of my favorite
episodes in the season
now together they train the locals up
and fight off a group of clatunians
that have commandeered an atst or a
chicken walker as i used to call them
but hey the 80s they they were their
best weren't though now mano decides to
leave the child with the peaceful
sorghum farmers
however he realizes that he's still
being tracked when a bounty hunter
arrives
and attempts to shoot the child cora
manages to kill his bounty hunter
but mando is quickly hunted by more and
more of them
which is when we jump over to episode 5
and see him being tracked by one
mando manages to take the hunter out in
a battle across the stars
but this badly damages his craft and
thus he's forced to land on tatooine
needing credits to repair his ship he
heads out to
the land of scum and villainy and ends
up getting a job with a rookie bounty
hunter
who's known as toro together the pair go
on the hunt for an assassin who's called
fennick shand
and they managed to capture her but toro
double crosses mando after realizing how
much baby yoda is worth
toro captures the child and holds it
hostage but mando kills him and we get a
tease of someone finding fenix body in
the desert
now we don't know exactly who this is
yet but chances are
season two will tell us that sp spoiler
alert though it's boba fett
anyway at this point mando is just
trying to get by
and he seeks out a job from a man named
ran who mana used to be friends with
their job is to rescue a prisoner from
his ship and along with
rand's hand-selected crew mando and
coast sneak onto the vessel
upon freeing the prisoner mando realizes
it's a double cross
and that the target is actually an old
enemy they lock mando in the cell
but he escapes and hunts them down one
by one
in what is one of the best moments in
the entire season
now mando returns to ran in order to get
payment and he departs the ship
just as they're about to fire upon him
however at the last second
x-wings arrive and it's revealed that
mando actually led them there
this takes us into episode 7 in which
amanda realizes that he's going to
constantly be on the run
unless he tackles the problem head-on he
teams up with queel
cara dune and even ig-11 in order to
stop the bounty hunters guild from
following them
by cutting off the contract at its
source and a journey to navarro in order
to trick the imperial forces
they meet kaga to make sure that the
deal seems more legitimate
and we learned that since mano left the
planet the imperials have ravaged it
wiping out pretty much all of the
mandalorian forces
now kaga plans to double cross mando but
after their attack by minox
baby oda heals him and he has a change
of heart the group send baby out of back
with queel
and the main crew head out with karger
now on their side
thus he does a triple double triple
cross way a double croc
double [ __ ] cross i think and he
kills his own men and betrays the client
on top of this
uh i have no idea if that's right anyway
in comes moff gideon who has his forces
shoot up the client's lair
which kills the villain in the process
he also sends some scout troopers out to
get baby yoda
and they kill queel which ends hence the
episode
i really sad no no i'm not crying look
the troopers can't shoot for ish and
luckily ig-11 arrives and saves the
child before storming the village where
the moff is holding mando and co in the
crosshairs
moff gideon knows all the ins and outs
of mando's past
including his real name and this is
where we learn that he was
instrumental in several attacks
including ones on mandalore which gave
him access to the darksaber
after a nail-biting battle mando is
badly wounded
and he refuses to accept medical aid due
to the rules of the mandalorians
cara and kaga go on without him but he
removes his helmet to show his face to
ig-11
who's able to tend to his wounds maybe
maybe droids aren't all that bad
the group then head through the lair of
the mandalorians and here they come
face to face with the amra who we learn
survive the onslaught
she gives mando the task of reuniting
baby yoda with the jedi
and this will likely become the driving
force of season 2.
the armorer gives mando a jet pack and
the team use a barge to sail through the
caverns
that letter the planet imperial forces
surround the entrance
and ig-11 sacrifices himself so that the
group can get out
everything looks like it's gonna be
sunshine and rainbows until moff gideon
arrives in his tie fighter
and attempts to kill the group which
almost ruins the franchise
more than the last jedi and the rise of
skywalker for that man now with
mando's new jet pack he attacks the
vessel and manages to bring it down
seemingly killing them off in the
process chalk one up for the good guys
and we watch as mandel heads off into
space with baby odor at his side
and a brand new mission whatever it
takes he will reunite with his people
and become the best damn space dad
in the entire universe however in the
closing shots of the show
we witness gideon cutting his way out of
his tie fighter
using the darksaber gideon clearly isn't
happy at how things have turned out
and will likely be hot on the heels of
mando as we head into the second season
anyway you should be fully caught up now
for that and obviously i'd love to hear
how hyped you are to see it next week
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video and
want something else to watch
then definitely check out our breakdown
of the finale of lovecraft country
we go over the last episode and discuss
everything you need to know
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more don't forget we're
also giving away three copies of the
marvel phase one box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see contents early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also become chapters on a
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul aka
baby yolo i'm sorry that was terrible
i'll see you next time yeah take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you